on va rentrer avec la coupe demain c'est
incroyable on a marqué l'histoire de
notre pays et j'espère que ça ne va pas
s'arrêter là on va continuer à
progresser a ramené de titre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas de l'année
il ya plein d'émotions qui se mélangent
là honnêtement beaucoup de fierté
beaucoup de bonheur soulagement
forcément un petit peu mais je crois
qu'on réalise pas encore sonné rien ça
fait dur ça a été dur en page abeilles
avaient un bon gardien ouais qui sortait
tout mais bon je pense qu'aujourd'hui
mentalement on était bien parce que
imaginez-vous sa demande ait raté un
penalty après un combat aux tirs au but
déjà si mentalement n'était peut-être
pas t'es pas bien ouais tu pouvais le
faire une séance des penaltys on savait
que c'est leur point fort mais bon on
est champion aujourd'hui on a fait donc
mieux le sénégal
t'as fait ça fait depuis de très
nombreuses années qu'on court après ce
trophée
de nombreuses générations ont été
proches nous en 2019 on a été aussi très
proche on sentait quand qu'en 2021 en
fin 2022 qu'on pouvait faire quelque
chose de grand on est revenu avec plus
d'expérience et avec avec de la jeunesse
aussi un mélange un bon mélange de
générations et et voilà on a eu en ait
eu un bon résultat et on va profiter
je suis quelqu'un de très positif vous
savez je pense que même en plus d'avoir
raté le penalty j'ai pas douter
heureusement il y avait tous mes
coéquipiers qui étaient là aujourd'hui
pour soutenir mon dit que ça d'autant
que ça va passer tu as raté un penalty
on est ensemble on perd ensemble on
gagne ensemble et je pense que ça c'est
que c'est le mental qui a fait la
différence c'est
bien ce que ça irait là bas et on est
amoureux on s organise encore pouvoir
gagner tes bras
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui c'est
condamnable c'est révoltant est très
contente très contente d'amener le
couvent dans le pays sauf en afrique
propre monnaie trop fiers nos vins de
france on n'ait plus envie de montrer
les unionistes protestants idole enfin
avec la victoire franchement on est très
heureux depuis 2002 on attendait ça on a
su faire on est les plus heureux du
monde a laissé le toit de l'afrique bah
si c'est le cas